et
stéphane le foll êtes donc notre invité
politique ce matin merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes le maire du mans
président du mans métropole et vous êtes
l'auteur de ce livre dont on va parler
renouer avec la france des lumières 7
aux éditions calmann lévy on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
face à l' jalabert bolobo jeunes du
groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france stéphane le foll ça y
est c'est officiel c'était un secret de
polichinelle mais c'est désormais
officiel anne hidalgo est donc candidate
à l'élection présidentielle vous aller
la soutenir j'ai pris comme principe de
considérer que à la veille un débat
présidentiel il y avait à défendre des
idées et un projet pour la france
c'est ce que j'ai fait avec mon livre
j'estime aujourd'hui cru vous l'avez dit
la candidature d'un hidalgo étaient
annoncés elle est maintenant effective
je considère d'ailleurs que au vu de ce
qu'elle a proposé
plus que jamais l'idée d'un débat me
semble nécessaire un débat entre qui
entraîne et vous entre elle et moi
cherchons sais pas s'il ya d'autres
candidats en tout cas moi j'ai fait acte
de candidature j'ai d'ailleurs toujours
pas de réponse du premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste
j'avais envoyé une lettre à blois
s'il n'y a pas de débat au sein du parti
socialiste aujourd'hui alors qu'un
congrès du parti socialiste vient
d'avoir lieu et il ya eu vingt mille
militants qui sont déplacés vingt mille
quand les congrès il ya quelques années
c'était en tout 80 et 100 mille
militants s'il n'y a pas débat et un
vote au parti s'il ya plus de parti
socialiste
demande est encore un débat mais bien
sûr vous considérez qu'anne hidalgo ce
matin n'est pas la candidate du parti
socialiste à la présidence j'ai écouté
ce qu'a dit à die de la goya je pense
que tous les commentateurs ont pu
remarquer c'est pas ça qu'elle a
revendiqué et c'est légitime
son positionnement moi je le comprends
je les accepte elle a plutôt dit hier
soir à france 2 qu'elle était
écologistes
la candidate du rassemblement
sa candidature a soit lent mais je suis
écologiste les écologistes ont une
primaire de ces cas les fidèles à sa
famille politique donc on socialise les
écologistes ont une primaire il va
sortir un candidat écologiste qu'est ce
qui fait l'identité et la différence
avec les écologistes c'est ça la
question c'est à cette question que je
réponds dans mon livre
si on part une présidentielle sans
affirmer ce qui fait sa singularité sa
spécificité
le risque c'est que les électeurs ne
comprennent pas ce qu'est ce qui ne va
pas dans ce cas là dit elle a parlé
allait s'intéresser aux classes moyennes
le s'est adressé à des gens qui ont un
peu perdu la gauche depuis quelques
années qu'est ce qui ne va pas le projet
il faut un projet pour la france
c'est pas simplement une question
catégorielle
ya rien de pire que de commencer par
exemple avec une mesures catégorielles
je double au moins le salaire des
enseignants fois vous avez fait ça mais
qu'est ce qui se passe les autres
catégories peuvent légitimement demander
mais pourquoi pas nous
au-delà de la question budgétaire si je
prends la question de l'éducation le
problème de l'éducation en france c'est
que les petits français
décrochent au niveau international que
l'échec scolaire est un problème majeur
est que le temps passé à l'école est un
des plus faibles de tous les pays de l'
ocde c'est ça la question de l'éducation
qui est posée si vous prenez un projet
politique il doit se situer à ce niveau
là et pas simplement une mesures
catégorielles donc moi je ne suis pas
d'accord présentera son programme dans
l'est
mais ce n'était pas un discours
programme mais alors c'est un discours
avec un record nature la preuve c'est
qu'elle touche mans juste du salaire des
enseignants
alors pour vous c'est un problème de
fond ce qui ne va pas la différence
entre vous et les algos un problème de
fond ou ce qui ne va pas avec ce qui
s'est passé hier c'est un problème de
méthode qu'un brin de fond je voulais
dit moi je pense qu'il faut un projet
global pour la france et jeudis en
suivant
le prenne de la gauche justement c'est
qu'elle est restée sur des schémas
catégorielles on pense qu'on gagne une
élection en choisissant des catégories
en parlant de statut
jaillir de statut dans l'emploi alors
que ce qui s'est passé avec ligier jons
et il ya toute une france qui n'est pas
dans ce schéma là et c'est la france
populaire la france des classes
insécurisés et celle là on lui parle pas
quand on fait ça insécurisés vous en
parlait beaucoup dans votre
les classes moyennes
ou schématiser un peu mais qu'est ce que
je dis dans la sécurité il ya à la fois
ceux qui sont dans les classes
populaires et moyennes c'est un second
des salaires qui sont pas très élevées
mais c'est surtout ceux qui sont dans sa
mire l'économie privée qui vivent avec
l'idée que ils peuvent perdre demain
leur emploi c'est cela qui ont manifesté
avec les jo d'ailleurs j'ai écrit un
texte sur les gilet jaune personne n'a
lu mais j'ai écrit ce texte j'essaie
d'analyser ce qui s'était passé et
pourquoi d'ailleurs politiquement
personne n'a été capable de reprendre le
mouvement des gilet jaune les gilets
jaunes eux mêmes parce que on est
justement dans cette économie et cette
insécurité la foule à comprendre et là
la gauche répond par des mesures qui ne
correspondent en rien à ce qu'attend
cette classe a sécurisé aujourd'hui la
gauche elle a perdu ses classes moyennes
et ses classes populaires
mais bien vous dites la gauche a perdu
sa boussole et bien sûr alors plus elle
a perdu sa boussole sera ce un nombre de
questions sur les grandes questions
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt ce que vous vous
arriverez vous arrivez à parler à cette
classe moyenne à ces classes populaires
j'arrive à parler j'essaie de réfléchir
pour parler à ses classes là est en tout
cas faire une analyse de la situation
comment on part à une présidentielle en
faisant une analyse du contexte je
parlais tout à l'heure des dépenses et
des système catégoriel
quelle va être la situation de la france
à la fin de l'année un déficit qui va
dépasser les 8% budgétaire et une dette
qui va approcher 120% comment on fait on
peut dire mais ça ça compte pas
mais ça va compter dans la tête des
français donc moi ce que je dis c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
hilale go a déclaré sa candidature et
c'est tout à fait respectable elle
l'avait annoncé elle a fait des
propositions quelques pistes de
propositions
la moindre des choses maintenant c'est
qu'on en débattre parce que de toute
façon le débat aura lieu ce que je dis
là il aura lieu
la présidentielle ça veut dire quoi de
toute façon il y aura lieu pas parce
qu'il aura lien sur ces sujets où il
aura lieu entre vous et endel je pense
que mes enfants je pense qu'il ya besoin
d'un débat entre nous pour pouvoir caler
un projet sauf qu'ils soient socialistes
et qu'il soit identifié parce que
l'écologie est un sujet très important
et je réservais des expositions mais
juste sur la méthode vous dit olivier
faure ne me répond pas qu est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous stéphane qu'il
allait faire est-ce que vous allez vous
aussi déclarer votre candidature mais je
ne moi je suis quelqu'un qui reste dans
un cadre j'ai une méthode du parti
socialiste pas le cadre c'est une partie
ceux ci y avait il ya semble-t-il dans
la modification des statuts il y avait
les primaires elles ont été changés par
un vote des militants on n'y vais pas
vous réserver la primeur aux seuls
militants plus de primeiro c'est ça
pimente à baron se referme je voulais
dit il reste vingt mille militants moi
je durant la débâcle soit un peu ouverts
c'est dans l'interêt d'ailleurs même de
celle ou de celui qui sera candidat
après ce vote parce que on ne peut pas
partir à l'élection peut sans cesse sans
avoir éprouvé ce que l'on pense sans
avoir confronté ce que l'on veut faire
parce que si on le fait pas avant de
toute façon ça sera devant les français
donc on a tout intérêt à essayer de
donner une lisibilité sur le débat qu'on
doit porter et je suis que neuf presque
je ne comprends pas ce que vous faites
si olivier faure ne vous répond pas
qu'est ce que vous voulez je fasse il
vivait for me répond pas il ya plus de
parti socialiste et ça veut dire que moi
je suis suffisamment responsable j'irai
pas rajouter une candidature à
l'extérieur du parti socialiste vous
voyez j'ai sens de la responsabilité
mais c'est parce que j'ai le sens de la
responsabilité et parce que j'ai
peut-être gouverner aussi et ça donne le
sens de la responsabilité que je dis
mais comment ne peut-on pas avoir un
moment de débat sur des questions qui
engagent la france qui engage la gauche
qui engage la social démocratie regardez
ce qui se passe en allemagne aujourd'hui
qui est en tête dans les sondages le
socio démocrates on avait dit six mois
et tous les commentateurs le disait
peut-être que cette fois ci les verts
vont gagner la chancellerie le dernier
sondage 26 pour le social-démocrate 20
pour la cdo et 15 pour les verts qu'est
ce qui s'est passé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé 1 ce social
démocrate qui est en collission les
candidats mais quelle il assume ce qu'il
a fait et il dit si aujourd'hui un
salaire minimum en allemagne c'est parce
que j'étais socialiste puis en même
temps il dit en étant une coalition et
moi je suis sérieux est celui qui est le
plus à même de succéder à angela merkel
c'est moi
sérieux et ambition c'est ça l'enjeu
sérieux et ambition c'est ça qui fera la
victoire sinon j'aurais pas dit toi
voilà c'est tout mais mais mais quand
vous avez une multiplicité de
candidatures à gauche vous êtes bien
obligé d'en rassembler roland lecoint
viennent-ils algo entouré de tous ces
maires un socialiste président de région
département qui ont gagné donc elle
n'est pas seule elle porte un projet de
décentralisation auront 180 quelque
chose mais elle est passée c'est
indéniable aujourd'hui le seul qui pose
les questions et qui demande à débat
c'est moi le seul j'étais à s'habituer
d'ailleurs fut un temps elles seules
aussi quand je soutenais françois
hollande tout le monde pouvait faire que
vous faites rigoler un peu
c'est pas un sujet on constate qu'elle
n'est pas si elle n'est pas seule et je
me dis mais comment et quand cela
suffit-il
et comment surtout par rapport à ce que
je vais dire sur des questions de fond
comment on va gérer le pays va être
l'enjeu entre déficit et dette
quelle croissance on souhaite comment on
fait la transition écologique moi je le
dis je veux une france c'est parce que
vous en parlez beaucoup dans ce
différend avec un dingue ou venez on a
besoin n'est pas du tout la même vision
qu'elle de l'écologie politique voilà
non je les dis sur l'écologie politique
je pense que l'écologie politique
constat qu'a fait olivier faur
d'ailleurs à un plafond de verre mais
moi je suis pas arrêter
la gauche je me suis pas arrêté à ce
constat j'essaie de m'expliquer pourquoi
ce qui fait que les verts ont un plafond
qui fait qu' ils sont entre deux
radicalités
peut-être de la radicalité mais surtout
l'écologie comportementaliste ne
s'applique pas aux couches insécurisés
je vais dire ce que vous dites pour que
ça soit clair vous dites la classe
insécurisés dont vous parlez on a
compris en gros les classements des
classes populaires n'adhère pas du tout
aux injonctions comportementale de la
classe sécurisé en faveur d'une écologie
politique chargé de tourner la page du
passé industriel et de la consommation
de masse ça veut dire que les
écologistes et qu'anne hidalgo ont tout
faux sur cette ligne ne comprennent pas
là dessus les classes populaires et les
classes moyennes je ne je ne sais pas
qui c'est qui s'explique moi en tout cas
c'est l'analyse que je fais pourquoi
quand il ya eu des rassemblements de la
gauche si vous ne parliez du
rassemblement de la gauche ait eu des
listes de rassemblement au premier tour
aux régionales oui et aux régionales et
vous avez fait un accord en 2012 avec
les écologistes sur les ai construit
pied absolument mais ce n'est pas un
sujet je pense que bien sûr qu'il faut
faire des accords voilà la question du
rassemblement c'est pas une question
pour moi c'est pas la question presse
ipi l on commence pas par là on commence
par dire ce qu'on veut faire et après on
se rassemble le vrai problème de la
définition du parti socialiste
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on ne sait pas ce
qu'il veut faire c'est ça la question et
quand on sait pas ce qu'on veut faire ou
quand on n'est pas audible parce qu'on
n'a pas compris ce que l'on veut faire à
ce moment là les électeurs ils vont
ailleurs quelle est la question qui est
posée c'est au total de gauche
aujourd'hui c'est tout juste
le score du premier tour de françois
hollande en 2012
28% comment vous m'expliquer ça alors
qu'il y avait
ils sont chez eux ou chez lui je sais
pas si vous avez lu mon livre
comment ça se fait mais ça c'est parce
que on a perdu tout un électorat
et revient sur les classes à sécuriser
et on s'adresse à l'électorat sécurisé
qu'est ce que c'est que lectorat
sécurisé c'est celui qui peut penser
justement des modifications
comportementales parce qu'il a des
marges je prends mon vélo en ville parce
que je me déplace j'habite en centre
ville qu'après quand j'ai besoin d'aller
à la campagne j'ai une maison secondaire
donc la modification comportementale du
comportement quotidien
elle ne coupe pas celui qui est au smic
autour du smic toute modification en
terme de comportement coûte et ça coûte
déjà beaucoup j'entendais des films
bateau c'est d'ailleurs les verts ont eu
un débat sur croissance décroissance
très intéressant sandrine rousseau a dit
non à la décroissance des gym bateau dit
oui à la décroissance qu'est ce qu'elle
donne comme exemple il faut arrêter
d'acheter des
habits neufs est allé chercher les
deuxièmes un troisième main très bien
moi je constate au mans je constate dans
le département de la sarthe des gens qui
font des braderies à longueur d'année
les friperies ils connaissent
regardez ce qui se passe sur la question
alimentaire aujourd'hui je m'aperçois
qu'il y a le développement des hard
discounters tiers les gens vont chercher
les prix les plus bas
et je sais que pendant la pandémie les
collectivités toutes les collectivités
un là tout ensemble on était obligé de
pallier à un vrai problème alimentaire
c'est à dire que quand les gens sont
restés chez eux payer à manger à toute
la famille toute la semaine ça devenait
impossible
la sobriété oui mais c'est très
important de comprendre ça je ne fais
pas que de dire je suis pas d'accord je
fais d'expliquer pourquoi et c'est pour
ça que l'écologie politique à cette
difficulté à pouvoir passer ce cap et
que si on n'est pas capable de réfléchir
à ces questions pour passer aussi ce cap
et retrouver un électorat on n'y
arrivera pas en exemple
je vais reprendre l'exemple des
enseignants la de ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure la question d'éducation va au
delà de la question des enseignants même
si les enseignants c'est un maillon
essentiel je voulais dit mais qu'est ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui l'école
reproduit socialement ce qui existe que
c'est dans les l'élite et les meilleures
écoles et bien c'est plutôt des gens qui
étaient déjà socialement aisés qui vont
parce que on a un temps scolaire qui est
le plus court de tous les pays le cd eux
et que hors scolarité et bien qu est ce
qui reste aux enfants qui vivent dans
des difficultés sociales rien c'est ça
la question c'est pas simplement la
question
doubler le salaire des anciens même s'il
faut revaloriser ces anciens et qu'on a
besoin d'enseignants mais on doit
d'abord posé la question de l'éducation
et du de la mission je voyais michaël
delafosse qui cite et j'aurais sur son
adresse aux professeurs pour dire
c'était bien de doubler le salaire des
enseignants je veux lui dire à michael
delafosse quel était le message de
jaurès c'était justement la mission
qu'avaient les professeurs ce qu'il veut
gagner un mot sur le travail aussi
puisque vous en parlez dans ce livre
anne hidalgo elle en a parlé hier de la
valeur travail a dit qu'il faut
valoriser le travail vous dans le livre
vous revenez sur le slogan de nicolas
sarkozy en 2007 travailler plus pour
gagner plus et vous dites la gauche d
statut protecteur doit comprendre et ne
pas se montrer indifférente voire en
opposition à cette idée de la place du
travail en restant enfermé dans la
conception alenia trice du travail est
ce que la gauche doit changer sa vision
de travail est ce que finalement c'est
la droite qui a accaparé la valeur
travail qui parle aussi aux classes
populaires et aux classes moyennes comme
souvent et c'est la droite qui avec
nicolas sarkozy à l'époque ce slogan a
été vous avez qu à regarder sur les
voies de perdre grand thèse avait
supprimé les heures sup défiscalisées
qui
alors c'était le symbole de simple à qui
elle profite et ses heures sup
ajustements à ceux à qui elle était
soi-disant destinée pourquoi parce que
les heures supplémentaires ces
entreprises qu'ils décident et que doit
la plupart des cas ils le décident quand
ils sont des besoins et que les seuls
qui faisait et qui se fait rénumérés des
heures supplémentaires c'est décale à
juste titre alors qu'ils font souvent
hors
hors cadre et hors statut des heures
supplémentaires donc c'était ça qui
était compliquée et que deuxièmement on
avait un gros problème c'est que les
heures supplémentaires à l'époque coûter
autour de 3 4 milliards 1 d'euros au
budget de l'état alors qu'on était déjà
à plus de 10% de chômeurs donc il y
avait un sujet par rapport au chômage
aujourd'hui on voit qu'on a un vrai
sujet de formation on a une reprise
économique qui doit être
accompagné par justement de la création
d'emplois ce qui permettra d'ailleurs
d'avoir en même temps des équilibres
meilleur pour ce qui est de la sécurité
sociale et des retraites donc ça c'est
un vrai sujet c'est ce que je dis aussi
dans mon livre et c'est une vraie
question qui doit être posée mais la
valeur travail ne peut pas être conçue
et ça a été trop souvent la classe
sécurisé qui pense parce que l son
travail elle le vit avec plaisir mais
ceux qui sont dans la difficulté tous
les jours la valeur travail c'est une
valeur qui leur donne une place dans la
société c'est pour ça que la question de
l'assistanat est très complexe sire que
ces gens qui disent mon travail c'est ce
qui contribue et c'est ma place dans la
société et ils disent pas ceux qui
travaillent pas ils sont pas à avoir
plus que ce que je peux moi m'offrir
les 35 heures mais il faut pas revenir
sur les 35 heures et 11 heures c'est un
seat est maintenant mais ça serait
catastrophique pour devenir par contre
quand je vois par exemple dans le
programme des verts voire en gip a tenu
son projet socialiste parce que il ya
beaucoup de feux de porter la mais où la
cgt ils sont sur les 32 heures et
semaine de quatre jours ben là c'est ne
rien comprendre
et c'est bien ce que je vous dis c'est
qu'il ya
bien sûr la cfdt n'est pas sur cette
ligne là même si elle a été sur la
réduction du temps de travail à juste
titre un moment j'ai besoin parce que
les gains de productivité t1 mais
laissait croire que c'est en réduisant
le temps de travail qu'on va créer des
emplois la preuve c'était 35 heures ont
été faites et qu'on a eu des problèmes
de chômage après donc ce rapport au
travail est une vraie question la gauche
est arrivé au bout de son rapport au
travail que je changeais poutine
beaucoup la gauche dans ce livre vous
dites la gauche a perdu sa boussole la
gauche à laquelle j'appartiens souffre
la gauche a perdu son âme la gauche
s'est éloigné de ceux qu'elle est censée
représenter pour qu'on soit clair c'est
la gauche on sait le parti socialiste le
parti socialiste dans la gauche
puisqu'il avait la responsabilité
qu'est ce qui faisait la force du parti
ceci c'est qu'ils étaient capables on va
reprendre une formule de faire des
synthèses entre différentes aspirations
qui avait une gauche de la gauche au
parti socialiste qui avait ce qu'on a
appelées cellules sera social démocratie
voire nous associer libérés ils sont
aussi quelques fois un c'était cette
synthèse qui faisait tout le monde s'y
retrouver aujourd'hui
a plus cette synthèse parce qu'il n'ya
pas un débat suffisamment poussées pour
savoir où il faut aller
entre 12 et 2017 n'a pas fonctionné
cette synthèse n'a pas fonctionné par
contre je vous rappelle qu'on a gagné
une présidentielle oui mais j'attends de
voir maintenant
de la thèse et ça c'est un vrai sujet
c'est que un certain nombre de questions
depuis 2002 depuis 2002 parce que moi je
remonte la fracture est là la vraie le
vrai la vraie problématique de la gauche
dans son rapport à les toits c'est 2002
c'est au fait les 35 heures ont fait la
cmu on est avec jose pas très fier de
tout ce qu'on a fait et on n'est pas au
deuxième tour et on analyser ça comme un
problème et on n'a rien sur le le front
national et on ne s'est pas posé les
bonnes questions questions de sécurité
question du lien ou travail c'est là que
ça s'est passé en coulisses
ce que je reproche au lit l'effort de
manière profonde c'est qu'aujourd'hui
avec vingt mille militants on n'est pas
dans la renaissance on est dans la
dégringolade et qu'on n'a pas eu un
débat justement sur toutes ces questions
quand je dis que les verts on ait un
débat sur croissance décroissance à la
sortie du congrès j'ai demandé ce débat
sur l'écologie on aurait positionné et
affirmer une position sociale démocrate
sur la question écologique qui posait la
question d'une croissance différente ce
que je dis dans mon livre la croissance
sur capable de financer la transition
énergétique et capable de financer son
modèle social parce que si vous avez
plus de croissance plus de richesse
comment on va financer monnaie sociale
d'autant que cette transition elle va
être impactante pour beaucoup de monde
il va avoir besoin d'accompagner tous
ces gens là donc on a besoin croissant
ce débat on aurait dû la voir depuis
longtemps et là ya une confusion entre
croissance et productivisme il ya une
espèce de rapport au conte à la
consommation qui est je le dis dans
l'idée comportementaliste de la sobriété
celle qui est un vrai pro c'est changer
complètement notre mode de production
changer notre modèle énergétique c'est
ça l'enjeu la franche durable c'est un
projet pour tout le monde danard
question stéphane le foll on a bien
compris vous demandez ce matin toujours
un débat olivier oui avec anne hidalgo
vous nous l'avez dit vous ne serez pas
candidat hors du parti socialiste que je
sens une responsabilité
ça veut dire que qu'est ce que vous
ferez ce que vous soutiendra un candidat
comme armes auront pour par exemple ah
non mais oh bon bout ne vous avais pas
lu décider bonjour livre dit clairement
que la démondialisation pour moi c'est
une erreur
là aussi quand je vois que est alors le
pire étant d'augmenter salaires en
supprimant des cotisations et je
transfère s'assure de la valeur ajoutée
c'est hier sur les entreprises qui
créent de la valeur ajoutée en france on
va rajouter une taxe sur la valeur
ajoutée donc c'est complètement
contradictoire non arnaud montebourg je
ne voterai pas arnaud montebourg moi je
serai cohérent je resterai qu avant mais
je veux dire ce que je pense rester
fidèle au parti socialiste qu'elle et
son carnet d'algos vous finirez par
wotan d'algos s'il partie soucis et
soutient il a des amis d'agde au bien
entendu moi je suis je vous le dis je
suis quelqu'un de cohérent mais je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui cette
jaillir cette désignation sans débat est
porteuse de beaucoup de risques
électoraux derrière et je veux le dire
est ce que une fois que ça se sera passé
moi je ne dirai plus rien ce que
j'attends de voir ce qui tout le monde
soutient si un jour ça va mal je connais
beaucoup de gens qui changent souvent de
veste c'est pas mon cas moi je reste
quelqu'un de cohérent et je dis les
choses telles que je les pense vous êtes
venus ici je pense ce que je dis merci
stéphane le foll d'avoir été notre
premier invité politique de la saison
[Musique]